[Music]
when patricia meets the gucci at aldo's
birthday at lake como they walk to the
you know backyard and
the boys are all playing this bizarre
florentine game that involves them
beating each other to a pulp kick
out come on she was pretty shocked
because she had no idea that a family
could be that violent with each other uh
all in game yeah
come on no no no you gotta go in come on
patricia you see her in that scene she's
just
wide-eyed looking at who are these
people i'm getting into bed with come on
put it on take that jacket off okay
[Music]
so that was interesting to me playing
someone who is aware of what's toxic
about it but is seduced
by someone he falls in love with and
suddenly is now embracing the thing that
before he knew was kind of bad for him
so when he leaves i think
i wouldn't be enthusiastic
oh my god
she realized that nobody has each
other's back
the father throws the sun in the game
and he gets beat up
that's it
i mean it's a hell of a family one
moment they're
fighting and screaming at each other and
the next moment they're you know having
an espresso like nothing ever happens
so it's a snapshot of all the people
that are kind of
angling for the power within this family
and uh the fracture of their
relationship but i'm starting on a very
light shot i'm gonna come down jack is
gonna stand and actually propose a toast
for me
i'll always think of lake cuomo when i
think of the cinematography of the movie
everywhere you pointed the camera it
looked really lush darius's photography
took even even a whole another level of
richness he set a beautiful stage
we had this incredible drone shot
approaching the birthday party for aldo
go over the tree go up up beautiful
and now start twisting around the table
and a beautiful shot right down this
very long table a coma in the background
and just the way
derek filmed it it just was iconic it
just looked looked extraordinary
[Music]
is absolutely spectacular yeah so we
shot this
big birthday party scene
and we shot this beautiful house which
is uh al pacino's place i mean locations
were spectacular so just you know
shooting in the great light and
don't mess with it you just don't have
to do much it's there you know this
conversation will be jumped straight
from that first shot
straight into this conversation here
from here we found this villa
right on the lake beautiful kind of
renaissance
palladian style
which was the former residence
of
the archbishop of rome
in the 16th century or might have been
the 15th century and the home of
bishops ever since
until the present day oh my gosh that
was the most beautiful place it was
actually freezing though the day after
we shot there it snowed which is very
unusual for como we may be a little cold
but we're here for a while we'll go
inside a little bit uh if we can make it
we
got through part of that scene and it
got so incredibly cold that our actors
were just freezing so we decided to move
it in
and ended up in that beautiful room with
all the frescoes on the wall so actually
it turned out even better just the
family
will come and sit here and have drinks
fantastic and
so we're going to make it a living okay
i feel so honored and i feel so grateful
to have worked with the legendary
ridley scott on this film shooting
across the back of powell getting
patricia in profile and adam standing
there so that might be quite useful he
gives it a kind of energy and drama and
humor and it makes it
he's a great filmmaker
[Music]
he's incredibly prepared he knows the
material he is an amazing painter so
even though it's four cameras he's not
sacrificing any shots and when you're
shooting with four cameras it tends to
feel actually like theater in the round
shut down you've got more chance of a
chip
there's always room to put four cameras
you'll be surprised actually there is
and the beginning maybe you put three
cameras wide and then once you shoot
those white shirts medium wide shots to
capture the scene
it's very obvious what you need so you
just come in with the cameras and do
tighter coverage this
is a conversation itself yes just cover
this then cut my team they're all
brilliant and they know it and that's
what i like so what i can walk in the
morning go yeah up a bit down a bit too
curly okay
that's how it works your ring is
absolutely divine
it was mauricio's mothers
you must think you're very special
i loved working with jonty yates i mean
she is an absolute genius regarding
patrizia's fabrics we stayed mainly oat
as in couture we kept it up in the
fabrics because they had all the money
in the world over here
we have
her
beautiful beautiful
outfit that she wears to go to lake como
to aldo her uncle's birthday party
thought song paulo's outfit dominica
you're the fashionista
it's
eccentric
i designed this myself the purple
corduroy as we call it uh lila
lilac that was a special one he always
thought that paulo was someone who
celebrated color and and took chances in
terms of fashion and his style he was a
bit of a dandy you should
reconsider your wardrobe choices paulo
you are gucci you need to dress the pot
i had a bloody nose so i had some
kleenex up my nose i had
this great suit on and
you know it was just a blast you don't
understand the thing about trans father
maybe it's
chic the physical transformation in the
palo was incredible
jared wanted to be hidden completely
that you you shouldn't see that as him i
just wanted to be as believable as
possible that was really important to me
that not that it needs to look like
paolo it's more like it has to look
believable because it doesn't matter
people don't know what paolo looks like
they're not going to compare necessarily
but they're gonna feel if it doesn't
look like a real person i happen to be
boris thing with creativity in italy
some guy came up to me he said
hey
hi papa excuse me
excuse
me said oh hi he's calling me papa i
thought who is this person you know
where in italy he was a strange-looking
person i'm so sick of you ignoring me he
didn't know who i was
which was great when it hit him um and
this is a testament to the makeup
artists
it was such a beautiful moment of
surprise and delight in his eyes
from the birthday we'll jump straight
into that
i just noticed again
are you gonna take it out during an
example i love to make you smile we as
the cast were all different instruments
in an orchestra because we're all so
different as actors
this movie is him conducting a symphony
not one actor i think had a similar
process everybody was different but the
only thing i think that we all had in
common is even though we had different
ways of getting there when we were
actually playing the scenes everybody
was present and people were willing to
throw away their homework in a sense and
play moment to moment all those things
that make a scene work we have history
flowing through these green and red
webbings
and yes we are expensive
but quality is remembered
long after christ he's forgotten when i
read this script my interpretation my
imagination caught hold of me kind of
brought me into a world i'd never been a
part of before in a world of excess a
world of indulgence a world of big
dreams big stakes but also
there's a tragic side of of it all as
well gucci is
doing well on my watch i think no no the
last time i
needs new ideas
new energy and i
happen to be bursting with creativity
some fathers are much more
powerful and they're much bigger
presences than their sons and i think
paolo suffers from that a lot you're
always brushing me off i'm a designer
i need to express myself aldo this snake
in the grass really a very jovial
uh gregarious man he's obsessed with his
ego essentially
and
that's one of the things that patricia
identifies in him and in what he's doing
and one of the reasons why mauricio
ultimately betrays him
on this son morning what because
you deliberately hurt my feelings
no no what i think you see on her face
and those scenes is i don't belong here
but i'm intrigued by this
and i'm gonna do everything that i can
to just be as quiet as possible and i'm
going to really do my best to fit in i'm
so sick of you ignoring me i am sick of
your talking
sick of it this is a scene about
power and family of course fashion
and uh certainly betrayal my father's
problem is uh he's stuck in the past
he refuses to take gucci into the next
century it's about italian business
and this nature of the transfer of power
and the balance
and how it
cannot just destroy the family but how
things that are important can go
unnoticed thanks for having us anchor ah
my nephew
he has such great taste
ciao
[Music]
you